uh I think he's
uh he's 19 years old he's uh playing uh
he's not getting scared of getting tired
you know he's playing hard and he's not
uh he doesn't uh H have to say this just
a
second
it's he thinks it's a big thing like
he's he wants to be good he's uh not
bragging about like it's not
did it taste
nasty
nasty uh I think like I said like I
think he's uh playing
hard and uh uh he doesn't take it for
granted uh he's making mistake with what
is normal uh I think the media is around
him doesn't help him but he's going to
get used to it because uh the guy is 19
years old he's the he's going to change
the game 100% And he already he's he is
already on that path so all the guys
just enjoy and watch the show and let
the guy change the game did you have to
make any
adjustments